[Music]  James Corden gets help from Dan Stevens  Luke Evans and Josh GAD during crosswalk  the musicals rendition of Beauty and the  Beast to be invited by James to perform  on the crosswalk outside of CBS that's  what we call a dream come true  wait sir with the blowing away yep part  of the cast joined James for the  hilarious skit on Wednesday night's Late  Late Show and since Emma Watson wasn't  there the late night hosts gladly  stepped in to play the part of Bell  totally would watch out Emma Dan Stevens  who plays the beasts in the film even  shared a steamy moment with Corden  [Music]  [Applause]  ignorance is bliss people really love  the original so remaking nee is like Oh  [Music]  you